thousands of workers at a Ford assembly
plant in Chicago had to go home early
yesterday after a worker tested positive
for the coronavirus now work did resume
later last night but it's an indication
of some of the challenges that companies
face as they reopen Manuel Bojorquez is
in Miami another place where businesses
are reopening resuming today in fact
many good morning what's the approach
there Tony good morning miami-dade and
nearby Broward County account for nearly
half of all the cases in Florida
that's why Miami's mayor told us that in
his view the city is taking it slowly
and he is asking business owners here to
read the county's 185 page rulebook
before letting anyone inside we've got a
plexiglass we taped up the floors
retailers and salon owners in Miami are
taking every precaution as they prepare
to reopen their doors for the first time
in nearly two months under strict health
and safety rules I think the pressure
right now from is tremendous to reopen
Miami mayor Francis Suarez says his city
is taking a slow and steady approach
giving Miami residents time to learn the
new rules irresponsible behavior or
behavior that's unchecked will result in
a dramatic increase which could get us
back to square one
in the last week Florida has seen more
than 5,300 new cases and 273 deaths on
Tuesday Governor Ron de Santos announced
five new lockup testing sites these have
been successful at going into
underserved communities giving folks an
opportunity to get tested De Santis also
pointed out that as testing has
increased the percent of positive tests
has trended downward and in some
communities Floridians are already
dining out and working out
in Connecticut salon owners and hair
care professionals protested governor
net Lamont's decision to keep them
closed
until June 1st well in Texas child care
facilities were allowed to reopen with
limits like temperature checks and
smaller classroom groups within minutes
of the governor making the announcement
I would say in the first three minutes
we got three or four calls and summer
camps in several states including
Pennsylvania Arizona Texas and New York
reportedly say they're preparing to
reopen later this year we're going to be
putting into place the protocols and the
testing to demonstrate that we can keep
children and our staff safe Jay Jacobs
operates six summer camps along the East
Coast and says they're taking steps to
bring campers back is it too soon well I
think if we were talking about April yes
you can't wait til it absolutely
disappears or that there's a vaccine so
we have to manage it the potential
reopening of summer camps could be cause
for concern for some health officials
because of a rare illness that could be
tied to kovat 19 15-year old da Rianna
Dyson died over the weekend after being
diagnosed with the so called
multi-system inflammatory syndrome
symptoms can include fever rashes
abdominal pain and swollen hands and
feet more than 250 cases of the syndrome
have now been confirmed in 23 states
though experts say most children do
fully recover
Anthony Manuel thank you